[Music]
you deserve the truth Oh
losers
that's not possible
is he in him claims he made a deal with
the devil
my name's me about her Mongolia you
gotta admit the yurt was kind of
romantic and we were so sure it was
there so what are the odds that it's
here in the family home of the guy who
killed the last person who had we've
never pinned this close we've said that
before what if we spent all these years
doing this science instead of looking
for shortcuts if we did the actual work
whoa
this is weird
[Music]
yeah
Oh
[Music]
wait
I see I've seen anything it would be in
German
no I'm really in English we are you not
seeing what happens
Joe German is your first language yes
this is not possible unless what if in
some way it is reading us
[Music]
dr. Bauer stay with us wait
hey guys it's Charlie so we're going to
be talking all about the secret origin
of Ghost Rider including the Johnny
Blaze Ghost Rider who is alive per that
scene on agents of shield I know
everybody wondered when they announced
Ghost Rider for the show where's Johnny
Blaze why are they going with Robby
Rhea's the big step first Johnny Blaze
they're looking for the dark hold in the
family home of the guy who killed the
last guy to have the book so what
they're saying is is that Johnny Blaze
killed the last person to have the dark
hold and then hid it in the basement of
his family's home and then as you're
panning around like the reason why you
know that it's Johnny Blaze is because
they talk around his name but they're
very on the knows about it but you pan
around you see the helmets the fanfare
the carnival poster that almost looks
like a comic book cover this is a chair
that looks just like the helmet and then
boom they slap you in the face with
three things you have the jacket the
Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider jacket the
motorcycle in the carnival poster all in
framed together if you've never read any
of the comics or you didn't see the
Nicolas Cage Ghost Rider movies Johnny
Blaze is basically like an Evel Knievel
type person with a carnival now this is
more true to the comics than it is to
the movies they kind of hyped it up a
little bit for the movies but in the
comics he wants to perform this big
stunt but almost dies in the middle of
it and then sells his soul to Mephisto
so that he's able to complete the stunt
and become super famous but as a
consequence he is now Ghost Rider he's
bound to the spirit of vengeance so a
lot of you are wondering now where is he
is he's still alive somewhere in the
Marvel Universe they didn't say anything
about him being dead that was definitely
on purpose like the writers were very
careful about the way they had the
characters talk about the person who
owned this you know family home of the
guy who killed the last guy to have the
book meaning that he's still alive out
there somewhere but because of the age
of all this stuff it looks super old it
looks like he might be an old man if
they bring him on the TV show but they
haven't said anything about him
appearing he does appear during the
Robie Reyes comic book like he shows up
and helps out Robby Rhea's towards the
end of that so we might see him on the
TV show I don't know if that
what happened in the back half but the
other part of this is the trailer at the
beginning they're teasing the secret
origin revealed of Robbie raises Ghost
Rider so if you haven't read the Robbie
ray is Ghost Rider comic book
he's like the latest person to become
Ghost Rider in the comics to wear the
mantle but what they've done on the TV
show is change his comic book origin
story just a little bit so in the comics
his uncle is dead and tricks him into
bonding with him his uncle becomes like
the spirit of vengeance that he bonds
with and starts killing people
responsible for all the violence that
led to his uncle's death but then he
learns that his uncle double-crossed him
and it turns out his uncle is this
terrible person gets tied up in this
plotline with his brother who's also a
character on the TV show but the TV show
has changed all that his uncle is still
alive meaning the devil that he sold his
soul to might very well be Mephisto so
what will happen is is I'll do a video
for that next week once the episode airs
be sure to subscribe to get it there is
a lot of cool Ghost Rider stuff
happening on agents of shield that's
kind of flowing from what's going on
with Doctor Strange the mystical magical
parts of the Marvel Universe and even
though they make you sit through some
filler to get to that really awesome
Ghost Rider stuff I feel like as a whole
this shows much much better to this
season so if you haven't been watching I
would recommend that you start at least
for the Ghost Rider stuff but yet height
and I'm going to be posting some new
Doctor Strange Avengers in a little
while and then if you guys remember the
DC like behind-the-scenes drama video
that I posted about Batman and Superman
stuff happening earlier this week I'm
gonna do a Marvel Captain America Civil
War one on Friday there's this really
awesome story about a behind-the-scenes
civil war with the Marvel Studios
executives that almost like crushed
Captain America Civil War the movie
so that'll post on Friday happy
Halloween I should set this bad on fire
in my next video well you guys wait for
that to post you can click up top learn
all about the Illuminati in the next big
Avengers film and you can click down
here for next week's flash trailer
thanks so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
I'll go get it for you